i'll use the lending money thing that i
got myself into
i knew it was a mistake but i wanted to
be the hero i wanted to be the good guy
there was a dynamic in my family growing
up where you know it was like she's just
like her father she's just like her dad
and my dad was always the bad guy
everybody thought my dad was a bad guy
now i've gotten older and i'm like maybe
he wasn't the bad guy
after all i was
constantly trying to compensate and not
be the bad guy look i'm not the bad guy
look look i'm the hero look let me save
your day which never
worked and i did it over
and over this last go-round where i made
such a massive mistake that i had to
really look at myself why did i do it
because i wanted to be like the hero the
savior the good guy why did i want to do
that
and then it kind of comes back to that
sort of childhood ego state of like look
mom you know i'm i'm really a great kid
look at all the things look i share my
candy
thank you for stopping by the pretty
intense podcast i'm really excited to
talk to this old friend of mine uh
jillian michaels so we go way back as in
like we used to be godaddy girls
together so it was really fun to catch
up with her she is known as a
world-renowned personal trainer author
and television personality but you guys
know who julian michaels is i thought it
was really fun we started off with like
life's big lessons um and she herself
put them into buckets it was like
personal uh professional
and fitness and then you know we kind of
kept going into each of those categories
a little bit more to kind of you know me
just dig a little bit deeper um so that
was that was very very interesting and
and and something outside of the topic
on some level for her right it's not
just like what diet should i do which we
did talk about there's there's a lot
more to jillian michael's than just like
the brand like she even does that
herself like she's a really she's
actually a really pretty down-to-earth
kind of rational person i think that's
you know that's what came through for me
in the episode so i think you're going
to come away with some really really
good practical advice on everything from
hormones and blood testing diets trauma
how to deal with your emotions and why
you do the things that you do which
include eating too much at times all of
that stuff really really good practical
advice so i think you're going to learn
a lot today good to talk to my old
friend jillian
and uh if you guys like it please
subscribe please leave some comments let
me know what you liked what you didn't
like actually just actually okay fine
you can let me know what you didn't like
that's fine it's all good information
but thanks for stopping by and don't
forget to subscribe
you sound great and you look great how
the heck are you it's been like a decade
like you said
since we were go daddy girls oh my god
buddy um i'm good
life is so different i don't even think
i had kids when we i don't think you've
been working together no
do you remember when we were at the go
daddy holiday party and we were drinking
tequila shots and um you stole um
oh god one of us stole kid rocks
oh bobby i do recall that i might my
memory is that you you are the guilty
party but it very well could have been
me
i do recall that my friends
something's changed some things haven't
changed i have a feeling we would both
still do that today
um but yeah i would still do tequila
shots with you and i would still steal
the brush a hair brush okay i kept that
brush for a really long time actually
especially just because it was kid
rock's brush
what happened to it why'd you you know i
finally just gave up you know i just
finally i finally moved for the 7000th
time and i was like well you know
say lovey
i do get that people are like what are
they talking about they stole kidrock's
hairbrush jillian's upset she threw it
away it's all right though i don't take
it personally even though i imagine that
it would remind you of me but you threw
it away but that's all right always
always yeah i i
yes of course i just think of you as
this tequila drinking thief
you and many others
so speaking of life changes like
i mean you have kids now
you know relationships have changed like
oh my god what what lessons have you
been learning over the last 10 years
like what are some big ones that like
you look back at yourself 10 years and
go and go
um
the hard way but i'm glad i don't know
that's so funny that you say that i was
just talking to um my book agent she
keeps like needling me for a book and
i'm just like i don't know it's been
said it's been said
and i was the only thing i could think
about writing right now is a book called
what i know now and it's exactly
what you just said it's how not to ruin
your life on the on that ladder to
success
and my god there are some big ones and i
would have to say
listen i i'm very fortunate my uh
my axe slash co-parent is a is a good
person
um but
you know before you have i would say my
one of the biggest mistakes if i were to
put them in buckets right where it's
like
if you said life and life was
relationships if you said work work is
you know obviously my biggest career
mistakes and then let's say fitness and
a few you know being reckless a few
injuries i got along the way i can
really change the course and the quality
of your life number one is do you not
have kids with an [ __ ]
don't do it like it's one thing to get
she's not an [ __ ] i'm just saying i
have friends who i've seen do it and
and um it ruins their life it's a prison
sentence literally a prison sentence
because you
have to coexist with this person and you
know one or more tiny little humans in
the mix that get
you know torn asunder between two people
that hate each other
and i've been fortunate to
have had children with a decent human so
while we may have along the way
had our differences had our fights come
to blows about things i wanted to move
she didn't want to move
you know differences about the kids
education differences about you know
their healthcare all of the things
we've managed to find a way forward but
i have friends who have not and i i
think i would rather lose a limb
than co-parent with a person
that it you know is just
a nightmare so if there's a relationship
that's iffy it's one thing to get
married because there's divorce
but you you have right i mean you know i
used to have it all backwards where i
used to think oh you know if you don't
get married you know you don't have to
worry about you know divorce it's so
wrong divorce is easy
the co-parenting thing
you know with someone you've split from
that's a completely different beast and
that one i would say is
huge number one the second one is
never what is it never a borrower or a
lender b do not lend money in particular
to friends and family
don't do it you want to give them a gift
give them a gift but one of the worst
mistakes i have ever made and i did it a
couple times was lending money to family
or people very close to me
disastrous outcome do not do it don't do
it like a divorce you just also say
goodbye to that money too yeah
person and the money oh my god that's
exactly totally they go together exactly
right jeez oh my god huge huge mistake
um
work-wise i would say you know as women
and i don't i don't know
if the world is changing
effectively
enough that this would be irrelevant
i still think
it's very easy to
say women are [ __ ] they're difficult
right as much as it's like oh hashtag me
too
and whatever you and i have lived that
life oh my god and it's like oh she's so
difficult she's such a [ __ ]
and
you know whereas men are assertive and
strong and you know very good
businessman yes yes leaders
oh
and there were so many times that i held
back for fear
of that label which i got anyway
and every time i was like oh do i really
want to start a thing about this
do i really want to be difficult
what happened is that my concerns about
the project
came true
the tv show didn't work or the book
didn't work or whatever it was didn't
work
and then nobody wants to work with you
again anyway because nobody like it's
success has many fathers but failure is
an orphan it's like they don't work with
you anyway so if you just trusted your
gut
it would have worked and they would have
had to continue working with you even
though they would have called you a
[ __ ] they would have called you
difficult so that kind of self-doubt in
those moments i think i've paid for
dearly really do you think i paid for
dearly
um
and when it comes to
physicality and overall health
oh my god i
made i have made mistakes that i never
thought that i would make and one was
being overly confident with with my
fitness and thinking like well i can do
that and i can do this and it's you know
crazy [ __ ] like racing horses you know
however fast across an open plane and
you know jumping jet skis over you know
six foot swells and and i got away with
all of it until one day i didn't
and one day i took a really bad ball and
fractured my um my l3
and subsequently herniated three discs
and let me tell you
i never understood the meaning of pain
until that happened and now i have a
very healthy respect
what happened
what did you do
but i was just doing some stupid like
crazy stunts and
ended up taking a spill
and smacked my my back
really hard oh just you know when you
get caught up in like the instagram [ __ ]
of like oh you're doing something
and you know
for
for shits and giggles like it serves no
purpose it's just you know i could do
that or well let me do a flying push-up
with you know your tip jump dip your
hands in water and all that crazy
shannon's that
you do on social and i ended up you know
taking being so dumb
just to see if i could do something
and
you know made a mistake slipped and fell
and all those years of like being so
careful and eating all the right foods
and you know building my core strength
and balancing my biomechanics
like it is second
[ __ ] it all up [ __ ] it all up
another one divorcing your body bye
bye
you can come back to me in like two
months oh my god how long were you out
oh three months couldn't walk couldn't
stand had to crawl on the floor
no uh
not
yes
and i say not yet because
it feels in my mind it's kind of like
having a time bomb in the base of my
spine
um
because i'm like well what happens if
one day
i make a wrong move or i do the wrong
thing
and
that's it you know you kind of only get
one so i i was working um
with a doctor named dr stuart mcgill and
he's a phd he's a scientist and this is
his specialties studying the spine
um he's kind of like this crazy savant
genius
and uh you know he got me through all
the phases of it
but i'll never forget you know i was
feeling really confident i was pain-free
and i was like i'm jumping rope and i
did this and i did this and he goes
listen
you will never
have your old back
back
but chill the [ __ ] out and i was like
wow i mean i it hit me like a ton of
bricks it was like wow i
i did some real damage here and there
you know in life you
oh you bring a meaning you give it a
meaning
and you learn from it and you grow and
you become wiser but at the end of the
day sometimes
you make a mistake
and it's like you got hit by a bus
you're you're living without that leg
for the rest of your life you know what
i mean you you make you make a mistake
and
you'll never get to that next level of
success sorry to be a downer it's really
more just like a warning be wise be
smart and the younger you take that
advice
the better off you're gonna be but so
often we don't pay attention to it until
it's all falling apart
you know what you know what i mean like
you don't read the book about anti-aging
until you're old
[ __ ]
[Music]
yes so right if anything i would say
like
20 year olds 30 year olds and pay
attention pay attention now
now is where it really matters in so
many ways okay well going backwards then
since we're hot on that topic like was
there
was there i just have a question about
each category so yeah was there
a last thing because i feel like i've in
my life like the really shitty things
that have happened i'm able to extract a
really big lesson in it or i'm able to
develop empathy
for
in a way that i never had it before
because i might use i might used to
think in this way like if i'm putting
myself in your position before an injury
like it's not that big of a deal you'll
be fine like make sure you do this and
like you don't have empathy for someone
who's going i'm injured you know i might
have said before like are you really
that injured like can you not do
something come on get out of bed what do
you mean you can't walk oh please i know
dude right so is there some like gem
that did you do you feel like your
empathy for someone with an injury
changed afterwards or was there a big
life lesson from being on the dl for
three months you know with the
with the physical injury yes i got all
of the above a completely different
understanding of people who live with
pain because everybody had a horror
story for me it was like
this kid this 30-something year old kid
delivered a bed because we moved to
miami and i'm laying on my stomach
because i can't stand up and he's like
you hurt your back didn't you and i was
like yeah how do you know and he's like
i did the same thing
and he had like told me this horror
story he's like i live with pain but i
manage it 30 years old
and everybody everybody i live with pain
i live with pain i live with pain and
ask jesus
so
i do think
it has yet to reveal itself to me how
because i don't really want to make
money off of it it's like it's not
really can't really be a book it can't
really be anything that i profit off of
but i wonder down the road am i going to
do something that helps people in
chronic pain that don't know which way
to turn that don't have the right
doctors that don't know how to feel
better
um
i i have
you're right a different understanding a
much greater empathy because before it
was like oh that sucks you know why
don't you try swimming
right exactly do something right
so maybe it's not stupid maybe it's a
character maybe it's like maybe it's
just an empathy and
a personality thing like you know
there's stuff that i used to judge
pretty hardcore and now i look at it
look at some things now that i've had to
experience that i'm like oh i get it
kind of like i'm so sorry i judged
before i know right you learn things
oh i know we don't want to get soft
because we lose our edge but we can
never lose our edge even in those times
where you say that you were tough and
you didn't or that you didn't want to be
the tough one or be them more masculine
sort of dictator on how things should go
and then it went bad like you know you
still got the name like being tough or
hard or uh whatever you still got it
because you can't you can't you can't
not have your essence or energy come
through
oh you're absolutely right absolutely
right i mean look i will tell you
without doubt you're right there's a
major lesson to every one of these
things
but you know i was just talking to my
shrink about this the other day i was
like look man if i got hit by a bus
tomorrow and i was in a wheelchair i
would definitely go the whole like
how do i inspire people how do i live my
best life i would make that i would do
my best to make those lemons into
lemonade however
deep down i would still be like [ __ ] i'm
never
never going to walk again i'm never
going to run again i'm never going to
ski again
and
while i would say listen
just like you right like let's make the
lemonade out of lemons what can we gain
how can we come deeper why is there more
intelligent and all of the above
if you can avoid getting hit by that bus
and there's work you can do
to prevent these mistakes or it's like
look dumb people never learn right smart
people learn from their own mistakes but
wise people learn from other people's
mistakes
if there's anybody wise out there
with us
to you know avoid it take your life
lessons in other ways but you are right
there are certain things i had to learn
the hard way
and that was that was absolutely one of
them without fail without question
you're right in business um in that
bucket of just kind of
being yourself essentially and and it's
not even just like a matter of like
flexing a muscle that you have to be
tough and be in charge it's more i mean
i feel like there's an essence of like
just like knowing
intuitively what's right and wrong and
speaking up for that so what changed
like
is there an example of something where
you're like i stuck to my guns and this
happened and this is an example of i
didn't stick to my guns and this
happened
um here's a perfect example it was like
how do we get
jillian
off of the biggest loser onto a jillian
platform that's about jillian and this
is i say how do we like my
business partner myself the people
involved in trying to grow
the brand that was my brand and not the
biggest loser brand
so one example would be um the spin-off
show called losing it with jillian right
and
um the head of the network
wanted it quick wanted it now wanted it
fast and gave us six weeks it was like
okay jillian's gonna move in with these
families we're gonna come back in six
weeks and you know there's the reveal in
there he was in charge and so i was like
this isn't going to work man like this
isn't gonna like you're gonna go on this
kind of like intense journey where this
person lost a baby and this person went
through like all these things that
caused people to utilize food as a
coping mechanism and
you need to move the bus when we move
the bus that's the biggest loser like
the bus has to move it's got to be like
look at that amazing transformation
nobody can do that in six weeks i can
come back in six weeks they can be 50
pounds later and they look like they got
a haircut maybe
the payoff's not there right and
he didn't want to hear it and he called
my business partner john carlo who
you've met you tell that [ __ ]
to shut the [ __ ] up or we're going to
rethink our entire
relationship with her
and i got scared and i was like
uh oh i better and of course guess what
the show didn't work
and then jillian michaels can't carry
her own vehicle
and then it was a disaster from that
point on whereas maybe when i was riding
high on the number one show on nbc and
arguably one of the bigger draws on that
show
um and had the highest q score at the
time right
and
had i maybe said you know what then i'm
not doing it
instead of having the failure under my
belt
that that created a stigma that nobody
wanted to touch right it's like well she
can't carry it she couldn't pull it off
she couldn't do it
had i just said no
instead of allowing the fear to be like
okay well let me be the good girl you
know i may not get this opportunity
again like let me do it
such a big mistake mama such a big
mistake
and then there are other times that you
learn where
i
i learned the lesson
i did learn the lesson but it's you know
at a big cost a big cost there were some
mistakes along the way in my career
where i'm like
she's like bugs bunny you know do you
ever see that bugs bunny cartoon where
he's like i know i should have made that
left at albuquerque and he's like
totally lost
looking at his map you know and it's
like that's kind of exactly you're like
god it was not supposed to be
here like it should have been over there
um and those are some really big
mistakes that i made huge
whereas
uh
we ended up
kind of taking matters into our own
hands as people were able to build their
own platforms podcasts right and social
media um
and i was able to grow and invest in
other businesses
uh where we where we had all the say
so
a perfect or not all the same but but
large control with a few partners who
are like-minded so a perfect example
hopefully is um a company that we
invested in called elia naturals
it's run by this mom of two who who had
two kids in two years with an autoimmune
condition and ended up you know really
trying to figure out how to to save her
body her body was just in shambles and
started seeing some of the best new
registered dietitians and naturopaths
and
functional medicine doctors and came up
with this line of like
anyway these incredible formulations and
these great ingredients and i i loved
her and i loved it
and
instead of licensing jillian michaels
for a product that's obvious about
weight loss which i don't really want to
do but it's low hanging fruit
i was like i really think this is going
to be the way forward in nutraceuticals
and supplements and we invested in this
woman
took her from a million dollars in sales
to what this year will be
26 million dollars in sales
and
she's got uh now went from a 9 profit
margin last year to a 15 profit margin
this year but we were able to say like
no we're not doing that and no we're not
going to market it like that and no
we're not using these messages and yes
we're going to do it this way
because we were self-contained didn't
have to fight with anyone and i was able
to trust my gut and
you know i had people around me who
trusted me and now hopefully it looks
like you know they're in talks to sell
the company and if they don't sell the
company
i'll keep it and grow it to the next
level which is 50 million in sales
um and sell it there but yeah whenever i
was able
to trust my god
it always worked and whenever i went
against it it never worked
never
never disaster
who can even i mean i feel
like if you think back to all the things
that you hadn't you know an intuition
about
and had that gut feeling about
and you go
was your gut ever wrong and it's usually
like um
no i i can't remember when it was ever
wrong right it's usually right on now
once
yep and then you're not going i knew it
i knew it i knew it every time dude
every time
just your gut that's a good lesson um
never bad to reaffirm that one even
though we know it it's like how many
examples do we need okay so personally
so
don't have kids at the wrong person
because it's a it's a life sentence
definitely is um i can see that um thank
god i
never did that um oh my god i'm
wondering if there's like an emotional
like what's a self-reflective lesson
like sure it's like don't
be with the wrong person that's outside
of you but inside of you what changed
did you did you change so that you
attracted or liked a different kind of
person did you did you create a boundary
that all of a sudden changed your life
you know
i think
most people if they're open to it could
benefit from
therapy for a little while and
in certain
families right it's like oh yeah i'm not
crazy i don't need someone to listen to
me it's not about that it's about making
our unconscious patterns conscious so
that we don't continue to play out the
same patterns that are destructive right
these repetition compulsions
so
for example
i'll use the lending money thing that i
got myself into
i knew it was a mistake i felt it with
every cell in my body
but i wanted to be the hero i wanted to
be the good guy
and
there was a dynamic in my family growing
up
where
you know it was like she's just like her
father she's just like her dad and my
dad was always the bad guy everybody
thought my dad was the bad guy now i've
gotten older and i'm like maybe he
wasn't the bad guy
after all
um and it's interesting because it
actually brought me to find a real
kind of healing with my dad but
i was
constantly trying to compensate and not
be the bad guy look i'm not the bad guy
look look i'm the hero look let me save
your day which never
worked and i did it over
and over and over again
um until
this last go round where i made such a
massive mistake
playing it out and it backfired so badly
that i had to really look at myself and
be like all right i knew it once again
right trust you i knew not to do it why
did i do it because i wanted to be like
the hero the savior the good guy
why did i want to do that
and then it kind of comes back to that
sort of childhood ego state of like look
mom you know i'm i'm i'm really a great
kid look at all the things look i share
my candy look i you know all that deep
[ __ ] that should have been worked
through and played out negatively
whereas
you know sometimes you have to learn the
hard way i am in therapy and i've
learned a lot from therapy but i love
therapy you don't need to justify it in
any kind of way i have one to two
therapists at all times okay i mean
it saved me from a lot of those mistakes
but some of them i end up having to make
the hard way
um
and another one i will say with my back
before i knew here's what's crazy is i
didn't know what was wrong with my back
because all right this is going to sound
nuts but when i fell
i just thought like i bruised it really
bad and then there was a lot going on in
my life and i was moving and it was
creating all the stress between my ex
and i because
and i was like oh
i'm so stressed out i'm just so tight my
soul eyes is really tight my hips are
tight well i haven't been without
realizing like yo idiot
you fractured your spine and i was doing
all the wrong [ __ ] and having people
walk on me because it just didn't occur
to me
i did not occur to me that i could have
had such an injury because i'm i'm
chilling in michael's i would never have
such an injury how could that be a thing
that would never happen to me
and
i kept thinking in my mind like it's
just all this stress it's just all this
like
this sort of resentment i have over over
this or that or this or that
um and my ex you know we're playing out
this dynamic or like she was kind of
like my mother right and i was like look
you know look all these things i've done
for you and she was playing out
something with me where i was kind of
like the
you know the oppressive parent anyway
the controlling parent make a long story
short
the same pattern
before dr mcgill read the mri i was like
you fractured your spine how did you do
that and i all of a sudden pieces all
together
i thought that it was like
i was like i've got to let whatever is
sitting on my chest with all of this go
and it's like the way they say
i'm being angry
and holding a grudge is drinking poison
and hoping the other person dies
right and i used to hear it all the time
and be like yeah that's cute but like
i'm not jesus so that's that's a great
you know love your whole sounds good but
i'm just not that big of a person and
they couldn't figure out right if
something is antagonizing you actively
antagonizing you like if there's a wasp
stinging you on the arm how do you not
get pissed at that how do you know
and for some reason this this thing was
my back made everything else seemed like
nothing
and made me realize that whatever i was
holding on to was stressing me out to
such a degree
and i still do think the stress attacks
the part of your body where you're the
weakest
and i think that all i was like i just
don't even care anymore like that
dynamic whatever we were caught up in
stopped i i i was just i was like you
know what
you're gonna do this and normally this
would drive me crazy and instead i was
like i don't even care i i i surrender
go do that do it i i you're the winner i
give up i surrender and in doing so it
actually
made
my ex
calm down
and it made me all the torture i got
from thinking
something was wrong or not right or
gonna be i just didn't even care anymore
i didn't have the ability to care
anymore i couldn't stand and i was able
to for the first time in my life
realized that
whatever
[ __ ] we hold on to
really i felt i felt the poison of
drinking it for the first time
and now i'm
99 of the time now
whatever it is and it did also help me
kind of reconnect with my dad after 30
years interesting
i was like life is way too short for
this [ __ ] man doesn't mean you can't
have boundaries you need you obviously
right like you have your boundaries
um but the bitterness and the anger
it's amazing how when i've noticed this
in my own life
especially with my family
that when i finally let go of things
wanting to be a certain way wanting them
to be a certain way or expecting
something trying to make a difference
when i finally just accept things for
what they are where they're at and and
be at peace with that or at least they
just accept that it doesn't mean it's
peaceful it just means that it's just
the way it is
um it's amazing how on the other side of
that
shift
they actually just start to change in
the way that i had always hoped it's
like the weirdest thing it's like we
hold on to this energetic imprint with
our opinion of them it almost like re
it almost reinforces it yeah and
perpetuates it and as soon as you let go
of that pattern then all of a sudden the
the patterns actually starts to change
within the other person
have you noticed that okay i just went
through this with my daughter
and
this kid broke me in half i'm serious no
one's officially broken me in half until
this kid this kid in conjunction with
stuff going first right
um well i i got them at the same time so
she's technically adopted as well right
so is it the adopted
the adopted child my my daughter yeah so
technically i adopted my son but my ex
had him and
right because god if there is a god has
an amazing sense of humor it all
happened at the same time right um so
this kid is just very much like i do
what i want
and
you know some of those things i do what
i want
you know as a parent you're like oh [ __ ]
you know you you just it's like you're
gonna do real damage like things i can't
undo for you and the world is
very different place than
when i was a kid you know i do what i
want could be like i'm gonna experiment
with drugs well all right you might have
a bad night you might throw up all night
long but as long as you didn't get in
the car
you know what i mean no one died you'd
live now there could be a grain of
fentanyl on whatever the hell that is
and it's like you're dead it's over it's
finished it's not baby laxative in that
anymore dude it's it's like night night
you will die
she's not doing drugs she's very young
but my point is
some of these decisions some of these
things that they get into like on the
ipad and these group chats they're
they're life-ending like i think you
heard about that that 25 year old maybe
who worked for teen vogue
who was the editor in chief of team
bogan at 15 years old made it like a
racist or a homophobic tweet
15.
and they fired her cancelled her
blackballed forever oh from 10 years
previous because now
this is it a girl or a guy he or she is
25 working at the she's working at 25
years old but now go back 15 years and
they found it and sort of basically like
ruined her life
it's like these things that like you
know or show whatever she gets herself
into
and finally i got to the place with this
kid where i was like okay
i've got you in a special program at
school we've got you you know
with a with a therapist we've got you
with a psychiatrist for atd like we've
got you with a tutor we've got like it
it and i look and she still would like
go blind and we do that and i i looked
at her one day and i said listen
on my deathbed all i need to know from
myself lou is that i dotted the eyes and
i crossed the t's and i did the best
that i could do for you and beyond this
you want to go around me you're going to
win
like you're working 24 7 to beat me and
you're going to win because i got to
sleep dude i got to live my life i gotta
work like you're going to win
you want to go out of the house in this
outfit or you want to say something on
your ipad or you want to watch something
you got around you caught it on tv you
downloaded it you found a way like you
got on tick tock you you did all these
things you will win
so whatever you do to yourself
like i'm gonna do my best to make sure
you don't get physically hurt you don't
unintentionally hurt someone else
and that's and i'm gonna live with that
and i'm gonna be good with that dude and
it was oh danica i don't know what
happened but the minute i like kind of
gave up not on her but on trying to
control
you know what she saw what she did how
she you know all the time
she the grades went from f's and d's to
a's and b's
and i i was like what the
heck
like and she you know she did something
she goes i wanted to do it mom
i [ __ ] up and i was like
and she's like i shouldn't have done it
i'm not gonna do it again and i was like
listen it's not that's not the we're not
i'm not the perfect mother
by any means and things are not going to
be perfect and i expect many more bumps
in the rude but you're right it was like
the minute i kind of was like
okay i don't feel guilty like i gave up
on you i don't feel like i there was
something i could have done and i didn't
do
and at this point like
yeah you still gotta try we're not
saying don't try but at some point in
time you have to know when to surrender
and know when to let go and i think
that's like a really hard lesson that
comes with time you can't you just can't
control everything you can't and it's
like it's that sort of omniscient desire
of like no no no i refuse to feel
helpless in the world like i i will
manhandle this i will make it what it
needs to be and the minute you realize
you actually can't you're not capable
that is that serenity prayer right of
like give me the courage to change the
things i can and you know the wisdom no
whatever yeah
yes it's that combo it's that fine line
yeah and i think in my personal
relationships it's like all right
i don't want the regret
i'm gonna do what i think is right but
beyond that
at some point you have to let go you
have to you have no choice
what about i feel like this plays into
something that i'm really curious about
and i feel like you have a lot of
experience seeing this um
with
with you know clients is and people that
you've worked with but the effects of
trauma and emotional
baggage
and the body i just i kind of have a
little bit of a theory that um
some that are overweight that can't lose
weight
it's actually like an emotional
protection layer
associated with because i think a lot of
people and i'm grateful i'm not one of
them have dealt with a lot of
incest or rape or you know less being
molested and so i think there's a lot of
protection layers put on what what what
have you seen in in your time with
working with so many people that are
dealing with that that's so funny you've
brought up the two things that were so
in the kind of needling from my
my um my agent who was my editor in
books i was like there's only one other
thing i would write in the space
and um
she's like well what is it and i was
like well it's
it's the reason
diets don't work right this is why
you're quote fat kind of a book
and which you cannot even say the word
anymore and
the answer is not physiological it it
can become physiological because it
becomes biochemical and neurological as
a side effect of repeated emotional be
emotions thoughts and behaviors which
can impact obviously your
neuroplasticity and your biochemistry
when somebody is using food to the
degree that they become 50 pounds
overweight 100 pounds overweight it's
it's an addiction like any other
addiction so there's a type of therapy
called transactional analysis but
essentially it's a decisional model that
helps to empower people over time to
make different choices and to see the
role they play and where they are now i
take umbrage with a lot of the messaging
nowadays of like you're a victim you're
a victim you're a victim
because if you're constantly telling
somebody that they are a victim
of who knows diet culture or this that
or the other even though yes at times
we've been victims and yes we've been
marginalized if you're always giving
that message
and then you're co-signing the message
if it's okay
you're essentially disempowering someone
to make a change so
we
make these decisions
gender generally unconsciously to eat
more
or to be bigger because at one time in
our life
it meant our psychological survival
and
it could be right so it could be that
you you yes you might have been obsessed
and molested it could be a protective
layer it could be
um part of fulfilling something called
an injunctive message so for example
let's say it's
you know the parent has their own
generational trauma right and it's like
don't be important
don't be too successful
don't be and maybe you sabotage it by
putting on the weight for those reasons
um but i can give you a very very
um tangible example there was a kid that
i worked with on the biggest loser and
he's doing great he's 18 years old he
showed up with his dad and his like
pears season and they both lost like a
crazy amount away like a hundred pounds
and you know eight to ten weeks
and
they go home for the holidays
uh so you know on the show it was always
like oh they went home there's a test
but it was it was the holidays so they
go for the holidays like all the other
contestants and they come back and
everybody starts weighing in this one
lost seven pounds and this one lost six
pounds and that one lost ten pounds the
dad gets on the scale and uses nothing
so the whole room is silent
and i'm like all right that's weird
then the kid gets on the scale and he
gained like six or seven pounds
and immediately all the other
contestants start co-signing the
[ __ ] right it's like ah traveling
and there's no healthy food at the
airport and like oh you know the food
desert and i was like all right everyone
shut up so that the next day i sit down
with this kid and i was like walk me
it's just we're leaving here take me
through every single step
so if we start out with the baloney of
like there's no food at the airport and
i didn't pack my snacks right all that
nonsense i couldn't work out i'm like
yeah
i know yeah
so he gets home
and the door to the house opens and
everybody's there right all the friends
and all the extended family
and they see him and they see his dad
being like 100 pounds smaller and mom is
there and mom starts sobbing and i do
not mean tears of joy mom is also obese
and upon seeing
right
much thinner fitter healthier son and
husband immediately feels
abandoned like they're gonna outgrow her
they broke the contract right
so she becomes depressed and she
emotionally withdraws what does the kid
do well he starts eating again with his
mom
what does the weight afford him
an emotional connection to his mother
and losing it has triggered primal
abandonment for him
so that's just one of the way now do you
think he sees it of course he doesn't
see it he doesn't know he doesn't
consciously understand
but
helping people
try to understand why
tried to show them how
what was helping them survive at one
time
is killing them
now
and then giving them the tools
to gradually begin to expose themselves
to these feelings they've defended
against for so long
is really the only way forward
and that's where things like
you know piss off a bunch of people but
i just don't care you know intuitive
eating it's like oh just stop eating
when you're full
it doesn't work that way that's not why
they're eating it's not that they're not
registering a feeling of fullness and
not only that
when you overeat you you've already
changed your ability to register that
feeling of fullness you've changed those
hormones that are signaling satiety
you've got leptin resistance you've
changed like they're starting to see
changes in the brain
in people that are obese thickening of
the
cerebral cortex and different synapse
connections and
because
and so it gets neurologically reinforced
and biochemically reinforced and
psychologically it means something
they're not ready so it's like oh just
you know
just so this way we don't feel
deprivation and
i'm like oh my god like not only are you
just barely scratching the surface of
this issue
but the only way forward is to gradually
expose people to those feelings that
they're trying to defend against right
right because
they think that if they
if they don't do you know otherwise it's
death right so they're still in survival
mode gotta show them they can survive it
basically what this boils down to is
everyone needs a really good shrink
yes
and you played the shrink for a lot of
people for a long time
yeah i did yeah but sometimes i you know
could have could have pushed a little
less aggressively
um but unfortunately in in the scenario
biggest loser you know people would go
home
so whereas you know far more responsible
individual might not open them up to
these things so quickly because they're
so defended you know that they're that
they need it needs to be more gradual
in that weird scenario you don't really
have a choice
you kind of you could go home in a week
they go home in two weeks you had to
throw it out there and hope for the best
sometimes it works sometimes it didn't
well all right thank you that was a i
think that would be a really impactful
story for people to hear to understand
that there is more to the story than
just the chicken breast on your plate
right there's there's a whole
psychological
um
understanding to
wait and where it comes from and why
so okay let's go a little bit more like
general dude there's a million diets out
there in the world right okay and i feel
like it's like the hottest time ever for
a million different diets what have you
tried what the hell works what doesn't
work and what's kind of the best for us
overall or what do you even what do you
do what do you do let's just look at
human beings
as human beings who want to be generally
healthy and fit right
there's there is an answer to this
question and it's very very simple
number one
don't overeat and as much as people are
like that's just well it's not true
yes it is there's no question that it's
true it's called the law of
thermodynamics
yeah it's very simple it means energy is
not created or destroyed in a vacuum so
calories
are units of energy our food contains
calories now whether the food is healthy
or not is actually in large part
irrelevant when it comes to being bigger
or smaller and there are two great
things that i i refer people to to check
out one is called the mathematics of
weight loss and it's a ted talk by a
biochemist named reuben meerman
and he explains the simple math
kindergarten math of calories right and
how it leads to fat storage because
calories that don't get burned get
stored in our fat cells
period fat is just stored energy what it
does in the body is a different
conversation but that's that's how it
got there right
and then there's something um this guy
his name is i believe it's mark haub and
he did a study on himself called the
twinkie diet
and
it's been a minute since i've referenced
this but i believe he did it for 10 i
think it was 10 weeks
and he ate nothing but um
oh god like convenience store garbage
hence the term twinkie diet but he ate
less of it
much less of it i think it was somewhere
between 1600 to 1800 calories a day and
he lost 27 pounds and everyone's like
well you know still probably super
unhealthy yeah it's definitely not ideal
but he also
lowered his bad cholesterol
significantly raised his good
cholesterol a little bit and had overall
improvements
in his wellness markers so of course
listen no skinny people get cancer
skinny people have heart attacks but
the first thing you do need to
appreciate regardless is that you cannot
overeat you just can't i don't care if
it's avocados or pecans or blueberries
or wild salmon yes that has a ton of
wonderful nutrition in it the omega-3s
and the vitamins and the minerals that's
wonderful but energetically speaking if
you take too much in you will store it
and too much excess fat in the body
messes up your endocrine system lodges
itself in your brain your liver your
pancreas your heart it's called ectopic
fat and it can come from an avocado just
the same way you can come from a twinkie
so
you don't want to overeat it's called
balance right and yes in a perfect world
if we didn't if you are an individual
who does not use food as a coco
mechanism you kind of do have the
ability to register when you're full
that's a person that's like 20 pounds
overweight right that gets dad bod they
get stressed and you know it's like i
really shouldn't have this extra bite
but i want it i had a shitty day i'm
gonna have the extra glass of want
that's that person it's like you kind of
know when
you could be done right okay i know it
i'm guessing you know and you're like i
am full you probably should stop okay
now
macronutrients protein fat and carbs you
need all three of these things you do
you do you just do they all serve a
purpose you need them all and the key
with these things is to eat them in
their most
obviously healthy form
whole grains nuts and seeds beans and
legumes fruits and vegetables right
complex carbohydrates fruits are fine
they're fine they're perfectly fine
they're great for you i can go on and on
and on about all of the health benefits
of pomegranate and papaya
and pineapple and bananas like beyond
like for example pomegranate helps you
support a little microbe in your gut
called acromancia acromancia is one of
the most important microbes and helping
your body to prevent and fight cancer
this isn't coming from me this is coming
from a guy named dr william lee who's
one of the best in the game if you're
not eating pomegranate because it's not
on the keto diet big mistake and the
list goes on digestive enzymes all of
those things all of those polyphenols
those are complex carbs all great
okay
now healthy proteins
eggs right wild caught fish chicken
doesn't it doesn't actually need to be
chicken breast it can be chicken thigh
chicken leg it's just once again it's
got more energy that's all so you have
to eat a little less of that dark meat
than you would of the white meat because
it's got more energy grass-fed
grass-finished beef fermented dairy
fantastic i think we all have seen this
episode of dr oz right no
healthy fats polyunsaturated
monounsaturated and saturated
it's not gonna it's not gonna kill you
you don't want a ton of it it's also not
going to have that functional property
of being anti-inflammatory
and great for your heart health and
great for your cognitive function that
the polyunsaturated and the
monounsaturated are going to have
so that comes down to common sense right
common sense which is we all know that
having
uh
quinoa instead of mashed potatoes out of
a box is going to be a better option now
no one's going to be perfect so when you
are eating foods
and i like to think of them on 1 to 10
right so 10 is is
actively
preventing and even potentially
reversing disease across the board of
diabetes heart disease cancer and all of
the 170 things that come with the shitty
diet and comorbidities from glaucoma and
erectile dysfunction
the list goes on okay
i mean literally 170 of them that are
all linked to being overweight and
having a bad diet
so top 10 foods are the the wild caught
fish the organic blueberries the all the
things we just talked about number one
foods foods on the bottom of this scale
are going to be you know
this place
and i'm all filled up on lawsuits but
you know the drive through
yeah that contributes actively you know
it's probably not the
best stuff with the chemicals and the
fake fats and the fake sugars and the
real refined sugars and the processed
grains and all the junk okay
i'm cool with five and ten five to ten
so a five food
is the food that's like the organic
version of
the potato chip it doesn't have the all
the chemicals and the pesticides the
herbicides the fungicides and all the
fake ingredients sure it's processed
whatever it's not going to kill you if
you don't overeat it obviously certainly
not going to save your life but if you
live 5 to 10 and you don't overeat
you'll be fine you'll be just fine
especially if you're sleeping you're
moving your body a couple times a week
or managing your stress level you're
drinking your water
you'll be fine and if you need an even
more
sort of dialed in ratio eat the five
foods 20 of the time
and 20 is very literal if i'm getting
1800 calories a day
okay well 20 of that is going to be
around
400 calories i don't eat more than 400
calories of
five foods
and then 1400 calories if my allowance
the other 80 is going to be the better
for you stuff
yeah
it's and then unlimited vegetables so
it's kind of like dude you know stop
eating when you're full use common sense
eat your foods as whole as you can
go with the better quality version of
those things where you can afford it and
where you can't be smart you know like
if you can't afford the organic
raspberry get an orange
less pesticide fungicide or beside get
the skin off anything you can get skin
off right bingo thick skin right so the
dirty dozen you can't go organic you
avoid thin skin stuff that has more
pesticide herbicide fungicide um and
then the clean 15 is the alternative the
stuff with less that you can get away
with not going organic with far less
ramifications negative ramifications to
your health but
a great book that i also recommend which
everybody knows about but no you know
not everybody is called the blue zones
and guess what you know these are the
people that around the world
that live to be a hundred and 100 plus
what are the common through lines
one of them is predominantly plant-based
and
i think it's like 60 of their diet a
complex carbohydrates right
yeah six percent
it's like grains
and stuff right
yes
yeah
yeah
and that that's where it's like i see
these things and it just
it makes me bonkers because it really is
just
common sense
yeah yeah don't overeat use your common
sense
you're gonna be good move and sleep
you'll be good would you say that paleo
is a pretty good guideline then because
there's still carbohydrates on that
okay so here's the only thing about
paleo it's it's not real and um another
great ted talk uh
on this one and i'll have to find it for
you but but um it's been an
anthropologist there's no such thing as
the paleo diets [ __ ] comes from uh a
diet in the 70s i think called licky
that i think was the caveman diet um and
the reason it's [ __ ] not to say it's
bad for you which is just hear me out on
this there's no such thing here's why
there's no such thing first of all in
paleolithic times
human beings were scattered across the
globe some lived in the rainforest some
lived in the arctic tundra
so the diet of paleolithic man was
extraordinarily diverse right they were
eating whatever they could get their
hands on yeah
spinach in the uh you know
avocado didn't exist
no there was no such thing as it was
like a cyanide capsule an avocado we
have turned an avocado into an avocado
through years of agriculture like we are
controlling these crops carrots avocado
through through hundreds of years of
agriculture turning this
and i get it like i guess like a if
we're using paleo with paleolithic which
it's short for right it's not the same
but i'm just saying as a guideline for
people is
actually a good diet like if we just
let's just call it failure just for some
different word it has nothing to do with
paleolithic time the failure diet is is
that a good diet
it's pretty yeah it really if you if you
kind of take away the yeah it's like the
meaning
um generally speaking yes and but if you
really needed like an overall obvious
guideline the mediterranean diet is
pretty much the one to go to and it's
not because it's
hummus it's not that you need to eat
grape leaves again it's
a blend of macros in their most whole
form it's the it's not a ton of animal
protein predominantly plant-based
high fiber
healthy fats it's the same story it's
just the right blend of macros
in their idyllic form but it doesn't
have to be mediterranean foods
that's if that makes sense doesn't have
to be a chickpea and a grape leaf for
you to get that same fat in a different
type of cuisine
or that same type of fiber in a
different type of cuisine it's just the
right blend of macros
in conjunction with a healthy lifestyle
big they're very social
they're active people they've got a very
meaningful life like again
go to the
when you look at the blue zones you have
the same it's the same snapshot could be
japan it could be the mediterranean it
could be the paleo diet it's all kind of
the same story if you were to take
someone speaking about like just like
the other lifestyle side of it if you
were to take someone who is like
um you know sedentary
sort of life ish like maybe they have a
desk job they have to ride a train or
drive a car or whatever like there's a
lot of sitting within their life but
they work out like four or five times a
week
um
you know really great workouts strength
training some cardio that kind of stuff
or
someone who has just an active lifestyle
never does any purposeful fitness never
lifts a weight ever but they're very
active they have a physical job they
are you know they love to go try new
things they get out hiking they have a
garden like if you had to pick one of
those people for like what the
healthiest what you think the best
the best
life is for um i'm gonna say
not longevity because i feel like i know
which one's the answer for that but for
for
for physicality for like if someone
wants an ideal
look
which one will do better
okay well an ideal look is going to be
the focus training in the gym longevity
and health is going to be the latter of
an active lifestyle hands down it's
proven it's well known
um
as long as there's diversity so
repetitive things
are going to create repetitive stress
injuries but
if you look at people that are the
healthiest in the world it's the ones
that walk to work every day and it's the
ones that are
in europe
yeah yeah
yeah it's it's a
steady level of activity
not too much physical stress in
conjunction with being totally sedentary
now if you want six-pack abs it's a
different conversation i mean if you
want an aesthetic then yeah you're gonna
kind of need to get in the gym and it's
not because it's not an easy thing
to obtain for most people so it does
require a little manipulation of all
right we need to blast off subcutaneous
fat and
being
having a look and an aesthetic right
is kind of different than being healthy
overall now you can have both
but
if i took a person that generally might
want to lose 15 pounds
to the doctor because they're a size 6
but they want to be a size 2
i would bet you
they're probably going to be healthy
they're generally
in fact there's we need a certain amount
of subcutaneous fat and it's considered
generally like healthy yeah but
it doesn't come with six-pack abs
so
you know you know what i mean yeah
totally totally and like anything like
the the don't be a dick diet that we
talked about um
it's like you know kind of like that in
life don't be don't don't
don't think that you're gonna have
six-pack abs if you don't work out but
also don't think that you're going to
live a long life if all you do is grind
and sit at the desk and then find a few
workouts a week to also grind something
out there has to be there has to be some
other modes
i'm curious about you know
you and i were we're over 40 now and a
couple weeks over 40. um
why don't we go to the club it's not so
bad thank you it's not so bad
what about the role of um hormones i
feel like you know even guys you know
when we're talking about testosterone
you know they don't worry about estrogen
progesterone some of those things they
might work worry about thyroid i mean
vitamin d is important and that plays a
big role but like i feel like you know
i've kind of gone through some things
over the last year and you know
figuring things out and and uh i've
realized that you know kind of the
beginning conversation about
i've learned some things that make me
have more empathy for others like so
hormones talk about it like
you know what point in time do people
need to have them checked or is it just
like a there is no point in time that
you get to you should always have them
checked and what the frequency should be
and because i feel like you know i've
experienced just like there's some [ __ ]
that just gets in the way and doesn't
allow you to achieve the results that
you want to achieve because life happens
yeah
um i
see this goes back to kind of that
conversation about grabbing people as
early as you possibly can even though
we tend not to check until there's a
problem right so
you know it's like why am i can't i get
off this 10 pounds or why do i feel
exhausted all the time or why am i
having trouble getting pregnant or why
do i have brown spots all over my face
or what you know then you're like geez
what's going on and hopefully it would
drive that individual
to an endocrinologist
by the way in large part it often
doesn't which is kind of disappointing
um but
you should you should be
going to the doctor like yeah teenage
they should be checking it man you could
have i had pcos as a teenager why
polycystic ovarian syndrome to the
hospital with bursting cysts twice as a
teen it matters it mattered then it
matters now and fortunately i had a few
things happen to me younger
that i
was able to kind of be very aware of it
that being one another thing being at
i think 30 i started to get brown spots
on my face and i was like
what is this melasma is that the
molasses bingo melasma oh the pregnancy
mask and i was like
exactly
what the hell is going on
um and so
it drove me to the endocrinologist and i
ended up writing a book called master
metabolism with
one of the people who i think is um one
of the best board certified
endocrinologists in california uh and it
was it was a huge it ended up being a
big best seller because so many people
were struggling so listen i would say
every year you get your physical right
you get your physical with your
internist
and your ob gyn
yeah um and you do all the checks and
scans in the blood work period and
they'll tell you okay your vitamin d is
low oh your estrogen is too high or this
is your progesterone is off or your
thyroid hormones funky and
i prefer
an upstreamist approach um
to to
hormone balance and i don't know if uh
if you ever saw this another ted talk um
so maybe i have
um basically it's how do i make this not
too long essentially the approach is
that you guys are looking for what's
going wrong
these kinds of doctors are looking for
what's going wrong as opposed to
treating symptoms right it's like oh
we're gonna throw birth control at it
we're gonna throw love with my rocks and
we're gonna throw hormone replacement
therapy at it it's not to say it's not
the right thing but understanding what's
going wrong is more important in the
first place
once they kind of are like oh this is
interesting this could be going wrong
that could be going wrong this could be
going wrong you'll be getting
xenoestrogens from too much of this cut
this out try this for this
you then if you still need
because like right now i i'm not on
birth control for pcos i haven't been
since i was i got off of it when i was
17. like i stopped taking it i noticed
things i didn't like about it and
started finding ways to manage it and
have not an issue
in almost three decades
um
i've always had a little bit of
hypothyroidism or i don't say always i
did
and i found out when i went for the
melasma check
and
when i started like going organic
removing all this crap from my
environment i had nodules on my thyroid
the whole thing so i monitor them
but i don't take any medicine for my
thyroid
now it's not to say somebody should not
take medicine i'm not a doctor please go
go to your doctor i'm simply saying
there are ways to put your body in
balance naturally that will help right
that should help prevent these
imbalances and once again
they're obvious
so
sleep you want to get eight hours of
sleep another big health trend right now
is sleep hygiene which really just means
what we all know sleep's important if
you're having a hard time getting your
sleep there's sleep hygiene to help you
drill down on how to fix it you know no
blue light blue light blockers and no
alcohol before bed because it ruins your
middle cycle of sleep and
sleep sleep makes a big big big big
difference
try to remove chemicals from
your cleaning supplies your beauty
products your food
they're major endocrine disruptors they
they wreck havoc in your body hence the
the term like xenoestrogens they mimic
estrogen they can create a host of
issues
and when i got off of that stuff
and i was pretty careful about it
the melasma
i stay out of the sun mind you but like
major improvement major major
improvement so the common sense of
removing chemicals where you can right
yeah
use the green
use natural oils on your face like
there's a million companies
i mean i've literally like i'm thinking
to myself i do all those things i'm like
but makeup i just kind of buy it like is
there actually like a good chemical
there's different brands out there i
have to pinch my cheeks for for to put
blush on basically like in the good old
no
you don't um and i actually
i want to say there was a book that had
i had my old makeup artist whose name
was paige padgett i say old because i
don't live in l.a anymore um
she wrote a whole chapter and i think
it's slim for life
uh all about
green cosmetics and or or you could
google it dr hauschka is one brand
um zoo zoo organics is another brand
um
i try to keep the stuff off my face when
i'm not working so should i make
uh but there was a whole yeah you could
probably just google like chemical free
makeup right
you really want to yeah like there's a
brand um of skin care that i use called
fawn lily and it's like one of these
same thing like
mommy run
homegrown
and she grows like botanicals in her
garden like i just got my monthly serum
today and it's turmeric and saffron and
it's
there's no not only is it all like
awesomeness which is great but
there's no under those insane chemicals
stabilizers and
stuff that makes things last for as long
as a twinkie does which is i'm pretty
sure we're looking at forever
and what you put on your body goes in
your body there's a great documentary i
think it's called toxic beauty came out
several years ago but it talks all about
you put it on your body it goes in your
body and it doesn't run through the
liver and the kidneys which makes it
even
that much more nefarious
it's like it's you know mitigate all of
that common sense try to go with the
whole foods and by the way the more
fiber you get in your diet the more it's
removing excess estrogen and
xenoestrogens and helping to keep things
balanced the more you stay active the
more it helps balance your hormones
when you you know when you don't work
out
and you have a lot of excess body fat
it's a
major
major endocrine disruptor oh sure i mean
even we saw with covid like
fat cells stored some like those with
more fat cells were at a greater risk
for
having
more adversaries dying in the virus
the cdc came out with this study and it
was like oh i think some crazy there was
like 70 plus percent
of the fatalities from covid we're due
to obesity
and i'm just sitting there thinking to
myself like this is nuts
we're not allowed to have this
conversation anymore obesity has become
a third rail conversation in this
country god forbid you say you don't
celebrate it because it kills people
you're an [ __ ] and we're going to
cancel you and you're old school and
you're never working again and it's just
like dude what
this is it's called science it just is
like
actually very like calm rational
perspectives to everything you know you
can watch some doctors out there and
they'll be like pushing keto like crazy
they're pushing certain things like
crazy and then you know here you are
that you know you can get
catch a little flack every now and again
for what is actually rooted in like a
pretty
reasonable
perspective actually
i catch flag because it's no longer
on message
to see everybody's so sensitive
you know i i find it fascinating that to
spare someone's feelings we would risk
their lives
that's the part that i'm just i'm like
and and the person who tells you
oh
you can be healthy at any size and it's
all good that is a person that's full of
it
that's somebody who's virtue signaling
to sell you something so that you like
them they're full of it it's a lie
yeah and
you cannot be healthy in any size it's
not true so
i've had that debate with a host of
people and like wow you know there are
people that are you know 50 pounds
over whatever and and they're perfectly
healthy i'm like well what biomarkers
are you looking at just looking at their
blood sugar are you just looking at
their blood pressure are you just
looking at their cholesterol because
there are
many
many other biomarkers did you look at
their microbiome i highly doubt it
guarantee you it's messed up do you know
what that's connected with and cognitive
function
uh immunity the list goes on and on did
you look at how much fat has planted
itself in their organs their heart their
brain their liver their kidney no i
highly doubt it do you did you look at
their hormone balance to see
how this fat is disrupting their their
endocrine system no i mean it's
it's like saying the earth is flat and
i'm not willing to do it i will not do
it i refuse to do it there are things i
won't comment on because it's not my
business and i'm not an expert i'm like
i have an opinion on it but i'm not an
expert so i'll stay out of it
i'm an expert in this area i've been
doing this for since i was 17 years old
i've worked with the sort of top
endocrinologist registered dietitians
physical therapists and the list goes on
for decades this is science obesity
kills people and if you care about
people you will care about whether or
not they are obese or not period well
you know you've
worked with quite a few
um do you i mean like you're such a
business woman i've always admired that
about you you're like you have a
business mind you think about like
there's just you have a lot of layers to
what you do
i mean you have a podcast right you have
a podcast you've been here you've had a
podcast longer than about anybody i feel
like you've been doing that forever
right i know yeah well it came off of a
radio show
um in california on kfi am 640 but that
i wasn't able to do live so we started
doing podcasts like when i say almost a
decade ago yeah yeah i remember like
seeing pictures or hearing about you
being in studio anyway so you have all
these things going on but what is your
why like what's your mission i mean what
kind of what what grounds all of it and
gives you the motivation to keep going
for the jillian michael's brand um get
an older it's not that exciting to me
which is why i'm like you don't even
like fitness actually that was one of
the first things i was going to ask you
is like you don't even like working out
that so it's like
i like what it affords me yeah it's a
means to an end um what i find exciting
in this you know this has been
kind of a big debate within the
ecosystem of
my
various businesses is growing other
people's brands so
i can use
the the jillian michael's brand as a
halo effect to invest in something like
a lion naturals and help get the word
out about this woman's company right or
i can help
grow another trainer's profile somebody
that i think is exciting and fresh and
interesting and that's why we took the
jillian michaels app and shipped it into
the fitness app
and
have added taylor walker for prenatal
fitness
and we're adding this this guy named
ryan clarenbach um who specializes in
calisthenics and we've got jamie
mcfadden for self-care and jim donovan
for
sleep hygiene
other people
and other businesses are more exciting
to me now um
i think just because it's like i've done
it i've done it and i and i like it i'm
grateful but
bringing the things that fascinate me or
the things that i'm passionate about to
the forefront
that's
more exciting if you will that's the
stuff that i i'm interested in you use
air quotes around your brand a lot you
then you when you describe it there's
almost like a whatever about it like
okay and right so
let's just pretend that you don't even
have to do that again there's no such
thing as julian michael's brand who are
you what
what do you love
what who like what are you at
i love
i mean i love my kids and i know this is
so like i used to hate when people would
say it because i was like you have to
say that and you're so gross
but the reality is
they torture me these little bastards
and i think i torture them but
at the end of the day
there's something about these kids that
it
for me
you realize you're
you're it's no longer about
jillian not that the jillian michael's
just jillian it's no longer about
jillian you suddenly become this
stepping stone to something
better than yourself greater than
yourself more important than yourself
something holding more potential than
you do
um
that's a fascinating feeling for me
and uh
sometimes i feel like i'm living in
their memories it's really weird
like something will happen and i can see
my kids
when i'm gone being like do you remember
the time that mom you know
and
it's weird so so i guide my life often
times around that future conversation
what's that conversation gonna sound
like when i'm gone like oh my god do you
remember when that crazy [ __ ]
you know like like i kind of live around
that like what i want that conversation
to sound like um
that's it's important to me
uh
and i hope it's funny
like i i just want them to laugh
and i i want there to be like the
horrendous times and the great times and
the funny times
but i wanted to have a story and
something that they remember and
something they learned from
that's really that
matters to me hugely
putting that aside
as a person
i mean i love animals i love travel
i love my fiance um and i enjoy those
things those are for me i consider them
like very selfish indulgences
you know i love
i love being active i love water sports
i love
you know courses and all of the all the
things so
you know being selfish like traveling
alone with my fiancee doing adventurous
[ __ ] is like heaven for me so we're
going to namibia in july amazing can't
wait
to have all this cool stuff and that to
me is like heaven sorry
love it and where i you know where i
kind of want to die it's like
how i want my life to end
because it's like where's it all going
um
who knows if i'll ever get there i hope
to god this isn't one of those lessons
of like a mistake i made along the way
but oh no you're gonna die don't worry
no no thank you yeah
who knows i'm all get to die the way i
had hoped but
you know i look at um
people like i don't know if you've ever
heard of of uh this organization it's
called the shedrick wildlife trust it's
in kenya
and it was started by um this this woman
and her husband daphne shedrick and they
they like protect all of these
endangered species and they go after
poachers and they take all these orphan
rhinos in and they they provide jobs and
education and health care to the local
communities in kenya and i'm like i
would love
i'd love to go out that way some sort of
awesome organization
that i enjoy on a selfish level
but that gives back
as well and i don't know maybe i'm like
how do you how do you do that like you
just kind of check out of all of it and
you move into something
like that
you have to like
completely let's go with this thing keep
catching this thing just let it go
and then it'll slowly
that that part of it
with the dissolves but what i'm saying
what i'm feeling from you is that you're
a curator
right you curate people's companies you
curate your children's lives you want to
curate your own life like you just like
want to be this i don't know like this
point person but also an in-between
between this sort of idea and
accomplishment and you're like health
care
you're right i've never thought about
that before but yeah
that's exactly like i would like to
curate the future of health i'd like to
curate yeah i would like
where what my kids kind of remember and
take away and build their you're
absolutely right yeah
that's cool well it's so good catching
up with you oh my gosh i mean it's funny
that we're doing it over an interview
but
i feel like i
i know how you're doing now and i love
to hear that i feel like things are
going really well for you and um i can't
wait to hear about what you curate next
oh thank you so much it was an absolute
pleasure and hopefully yeah if you get
out to miami let me know we'll have to
do it in person good in the meantime
i'll just have to use your fitness app
and work out with you
well yeah right you need that you
definitely yeah
you definitely got to start working out
girl i was worried about you she should
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button